there are nearly one and a half million
wheelchair users in the UK many struggle
with off-road terrains which can be
tough to handle in a regular wheelchair
tim morgan has come up with a solution
the mountain trike an all-terrain
wheelchair that is as comfortable on
sand as on snow it came really from my
mountain bike experience so I raced
downhill in the Welsh national downhill
mountain bike Championships and in doing
those races I do sometimes see people
get hurt and that's what got me thinking
about what wheelchairs were around and
they didn't seem to be an all-terrain
wheelchair that was off-road capable but
also practical many of the wheelchair
uses that Tim spoke to during his
research said there were activities they
wanted to take part in and places they
wanted to go but there wasn't an
accessible product out there the main
feature of the mountain trike really are
the lever drive so the idea of the
levers is that the person doesn't need
to touch the wheels to propel it so
they've got much more efficient Drive
but they also keep their hands nice and
clean in all weathers the lever drives a
chain and sprocket system similar to on
a mountain bike
so the user simply pushes forwards to go
forwards steering is similar to using a
joystick it also means that you can ride
the trike one-handed some extent because
all your steering is off one hand so
even if you're only pushing one side you
can still keep yourself in a nice
straight course so that's great if
you're holding hands with a partner or
on the phone or carrying something the
beauty of the mountain trail because
that suddenly I'm getting out under my
own steam so I'm exercising I'm raising
my heartbeat I'm feeling good about the
exercise it retails for a little shy of
4000 pounds around the same as a top-end
mountain bike and it's not cheap to make
the challenge is turning it into a
sustainable business someone who's done
just that is apprentice winner tom
pillar oh we got his thoughts on the
trike sir fantastic feat of engineering
and design he's kind of challenges how
do we take this and actually turn a
company around this first product and so
he's got this really kind of how do I
turn this one
product into a portfolio of products is
right at the moment we have one product
that have got lots of plans to build on
that and build a range of various
different mountain trikes that will just
widen our ability to meet the needs of
more people tim has recently won
approval to sell the trike in the US
that could mean as many as half a
million people could have it in the
future